bonjour Samuel bonjour à tous bienvenue
au bord de télémataire
ils ont pas le droit d'articuler c'est
une tendance qui cumule des millions de
vues sur TikTok fait faire des grimaces
et s'accompagne en général d'un son
[Musique]
voici le mawing son objectif obtenir une
mâchoire carrée davantage dessiné
et on croir les internautes le moyen d'y
parvenir serait une simple gymnastique
de la langue ça va peser l'ours sur nos
finances ou pas
de santé
le bout de votre langue juste derrière
vos dents du haut ensuite pressez toute
la langue sur l'ensemble du palais puis
alignez vos dents du haut et du bas et
fermez la bouche
une technique principalement plébiscitée
par les hommes pour atteindre l'un des
idéaux de beauté masculine Thibault a
testé cette méthode il y a quatre ans
pour bien faire la pratique etc les amis
vous savez c'est ça le fou rire en télé
je ne sais pas si ça va aller mieux
c'est la fatigue et honnêtement
Maxime est-ce qu'on sait comment la la
famille les proches de Karine réagissent
depuis malheureusement ce dénouement
très bien ils sont heureux
les proches de Karine je suis désolé
j'ai assez la vie la télé c'est la vie
il y a pas assez excuser une rare photo
du poète Arthur Rimbaud a fait le tour
des réseaux sociaux censé avoir été
prise en 1871 elle est en réalité
générée par une intelligence
artificielle sur facebook son auteur a
pourtant prévenu qu'il remontait le
temps de façon moderne mais l'image
inspirée d'un vrai portrait fait débat
auprès des internautes
certains admirent la reproduction
presque parfaite d'un jour plutôt gris
du jeune homme d'autres la préfère en
couleur enfin quelques-uns dénonce avoir
été induit en erreur
notre ratio d'être sur PIB aurait été
largement supérieur en raison de
l'effondrement de l'activité notre
déficit et notre dette la soutenabilité
de notre dette une dette soutenable a
recourir à la tête la soutenabilité de
notre dette la maîtrise de la dette et
maîtrise de la dette laissez filer la
dette et plus d'impôts
ne veut pas on démordre borné
très bien dans le viseur de Bercy les
arrêts maladie de plus en plus nombreux
6,4 millions en 2012
8,8 millions en 2022 pour Bruno Le Maire
c'est trop est-ce que quelque chose
justifie que les arrêts maladie et
augmenter de 30 % au cours des dernières
années ça représente une dépense totale
de 16 milliards d'euros par an sur des
vidéos où l'on voit des souris qui
jaillissent d'un carton de stockage des
produits grignotés par les rongeurs et
des cadavres d'animaux
à travers les yeux humides et la voix
émue de cette salarié préférant rester
anonyme l'angoisse de retourner à
l'entrepôt chaque matin on travaille
avec une boule au ventre car de faire
mordre peur de tomber malade de choper
des virus et oui on est maltraité il
s'en fiche le gouvernement
sollicitera-t-il les salariés en
ajoutant un jour de carence c'est-à-dire
un jour d'arrêt maladie non payé
supplémentaire
hors de question pour cet employé
quatrième par exemple
on est censé travailler dans une
entreprise propre des conditions de
travail dégradées et le risque pour les
clients de recevoir des produits
infestés explique Jean silver Guillon
aux membres du comité social et
économique de l'entreprise des produits
souillés par l'urine voire les
défections des rongeurs et donc pas
impossible que des clients aient reçu
des articles souillés est-ce que c'est
une idée séduisante pour vous là de de
payer les vacances pour tous
[Musique]
faut arrêter
en vacances on peut pas avoir d'iPhone
on n'achète pas d'iPhone faut arrêter
alors lui il a une tête de tueur elle
est en lui c'est
comme dans Nikita le nettoyeur c'est
pareil c'est
oui Alexandre vous êtes bien d'accord
que effectivement les chômeurs aussi ont
le droit de partir en vacances
vous voyez pas
de sous pour partir en vacances et ben
on va faire le service dans un
restaurant et on partira au mois de
septembre on va commencer en ayant mis
des sous de côté de juillet août
carrément méchant jamais content
j'avais en échange jamais content ce
thème me fait penser à une magnifique
chanson de Michel Jonasz on allait au
bord de la mer avec mon père ma sœur ma
mère regardez les autres gens comment
ils dépensaient leur argent et nous on
suçait des glaces à l'eau et on
regardait les bateaux qui n'étaient pas
nos bateaux donc c'était les vacances
bon marché mais on bougeait quand même
et regardez
sorte du bec de la cruche sornette
la cruche
on attend magnifique après 4 ans
ou très peu de gens en tout cas regarde
les voiliers qui continuent d'arriver
sur les bords de Seine bien sûr de nous
avoir suivi rendez-vous à la prochaine
alarme en 2027 images très rare d'un
zoom ultra HD sur un préservatif
très rare et ce nettoyeur ne fait pas
les choses à moitié
il grimpe carrément dans le tiroir de
notre cuisine pour nous prouver sa
solidité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le 5 janvier dernier elle est sa fille
sont à la gare Montparnasse alors
qu'elle s'apprête à monter dans le train
Neco s'échapper se réfugie sur les rails
sous le TGV franchement
vous êtes des peureux le train il est
immobile entre la boîte tu vas le
chercher le chat
et demander à ce que les agents SNCF
présentent nous aident soit qu'il
retarde le train soit qui roule
doucement le train ce qui préviennent le
conducteur et ils ont rien voulu savoir
au départ du Train le chat est tué sur
le coup franchement mais vous êtes mais
comment mais quel monde la France
entière a donc appris que le monde
évidemment mais vous êtes en porcelaine
aujourd'hui